carlos cristobal marquez owns one of
havana's most successful private
restaurants
a must even for the most high profile
visitors
until now his customers paid in cooks or
cucs
a state invented substitute for the us
dollar worth 25 times more than the
cuban peso
but now the kook is being scrapped and
with it
an unsustainable dual currency and
exchange rate system
it just means the elimination of a
currency that was circulating for a long
time
and reactivating our national currency
the peso
if only it were that simple one of the
most
common phrases in cuba is nois facil
or it's not easy
and that's the perfect way to describe
the risky elimination of cuba's second
currency
while it's considered to be hard
currency it's in fact worthless outside
of cuba
hindering exports and desperately needed
investments
when the cook was put into circulation
it was pegged to the dollar but in time
it lost value
its elimination in general terms is
positive but there will be collateral
damage
first and foremost a devaluation of the
peso against the us dollar
and a steep increase in prices which
means purchasing power will drop
despite the much higher promise salaries
i don't see the point they raise your
salary but they triple or quadruple the
price of the dollar which we need to buy
all the basics
and that's the other big problem if you
want to buy anything from
food to clothes or even hygiene products
you need to go to one of the more than
120 dollar stores
and that's why all these people are
lining up in front of the bank
to exchange hard currency for an
electronic debit card in
mlc the cuban name for the us greenback
cash transactions aren't allowed
not everyone has family abroad who can
send money
if you don't work with tourists you
don't have access to hard currency
this change has been very bad it will be
a difficult process for a country that
is already suffering from a deep
recession
scarcity and harsh new us economic
sanctions
but then as they say getting cuba's
finances in order
won't be easy lucia newman al jazeera